Daniel Jeremiah here on the Rich Eisen
show didn't know Tony knock on the
Padres yeah we were close it's this and
that rich that's you were though it
seriously that you or yeah we have all
that we have oh I think Nomos working
for the Padres now we have all these
different connections to him okay I
think there's affiliation with the
Padres and his team and I really believe
that could have been the difference
between 60 and 70 wins for us what could
have been well before we get to our
football chat while we're on the subject
of Mookie Betts the old gents data rater
this is really great based on what he
did last night
hit it brought to you by true car car
shop and can be confusing terms like
dealer price list price invoice guess
what true car makes it so simple because
it just basically shows you what other
people paid for the car you wants you
can recognize a good price when you were
at price when you're already speaking of
price David Price won last night when
you're ready to buy a newer you scarf is
a true car to enjoy a more confident car
buying experience he became the third
player age 25 or younger with three or
more career three home run games because
that was just the first of three for
Mookie Betts last night the others Boog
Powell 1963 to 1966 and Ralph Kiner from
1947 to 1948 but we're gonna do you one
better third career game with three or
more home runs ties Ted Williams for
most such games in the history of the
Red Sox and in the history of baseball
since 1908
two walks and three home runs for the
leadoff spot the only player to do it
Mookie Betts old gents dad and I
actually grew up with a guy named Boog
and now I know maybe where he got his
name from did you not put that together
no no I never he was a good baseball
player his name was Boog I though this
is a very unique name
Boog Powell's on all those Miller like
commercials back in the day
you don't remember those no my
commercials with Madden
yeah you know and yeah it's no it's not
ringing a bell okay then hit a couple
times rich all right let's get to it
what back in Apple is our turf they're a
tap state tell me about it
although wasn't a tap state all right
moving on yeah why Josh Allen for the
Browns in your mock draft number one
overall why did I ended up I ended up
going stuck with with Darnell in it so
I've had Darnell through the whole
process I almost made the switch at the
last minute to put Josh Allen in there
and if I went by what I was hearing so
you went with darn yeah I have Donald
okay I got some faulty a faulty no no no
no I got it now go for it I normally do
these and I've told you this before on
mock drafts I usually go by what I'm
hearing not by what necessarily I would
do right this was the one exception
because if I went on what I'm hearing
with the number one pick overwhelmingly
you hear Josh and Josh challenge a
challenge right with folks around the
league and then I actually even typed it
in and it just said this doesn't this
doesn't feel right I just can't see him
doing this so I went ahead and stuck
with Sam Donald there so you would agree
with the brown selection of darn old
yeah I think that should I think that
should be the pick and then the Giants
you have them going say Quon yep had him
going say Quan Barclay there and kind of
go back and forth and I just keep coming
back I mean when you make such a
statement I know everybody's referenced
it a million times but when you make
this statement we want a guy we can
envision in a gold jacket to me it's
like okay well who's the best candidate
for that it's the best player in the
draft and that's say Kwan Barclay so
that's why I went there
so what about all the conversation that
it could be chub or another quarterback
you don't you think that the Giants are
taking a look at everything around and
saying Eli still a better option with
Davis Webb yeah I mean I think it would
be to me it would be more interesting if
if Darnell didn't go one say if Josh
Allen goes one I think they have maybe
more of a decision to make there maybe
they do go quarterback maybe that is Sam
Donald there but I think if they're
they're gonna stick right there darn
olds off the board you know I think Eli
at 37 but Dave gentleman's been there
around good Eli when they've when
they've won championships and maybe he
feels like he can hold on a couple more
years and give him some help instead of
trying to replace him why Sam Donald the
best according to your yeah to me I've
I've had him as the best guy through the
whole prom
and talk about what he does in the
framework of the offense but then what
makes him special is what he can do
under pressure when things break down
the creativity that he brings I think
him and Rosen are the top two guys and I
think the difference between him and
Josh or that Sam can create and Sam can
take a beating
I mean Sam has been able to get up from
the mat each and every time the
durability thing with Josh I think
that's a legitimate concern you know I
watched I was at the Cotton Bowl Sam get
hit 27 times when I went back and
charted that against Ohio State wasn't
his best game we threw for 350 yards but
more impressively to me the dude got up
play after play after play and he got
smoked in that game so his toughness to
me is a big deal
the last thing rich to is Sam Donald's
20 he's I think it's two years and four
months on draft day he'll be younger
than Carson Wentz so if you if you look
at it in that frame of mind and say okay
he's got some time here you get plenty
of time
Daniel Jeremiah here in the Rich Eisen
show so with the Jets sitting there at
3:00 and every quarterback not named
Arnold off the board who do you think
they'd go personally I would take Josh
Rosen I think that would be a good pick
for them but why do you think that would
be a good pick on I think he's I think
it comes down with the Jets I I don't
see where you are on this I think
whoever the Jets take will get on the
field fastest of any of these rookie
quarterbacks so to me you're looking at
guys that are ready to play early and
that comes down to two guys that's
Mayfield and that's Josh Rosen now I
think josh is a more polished player
working inside the pocket um I think
he's gonna be a little bit more advanced
than Baker is coming in the door I think
both those guys can get on the field and
I think with where their offensive line
is right now I think Baker's mobility
could be a little bit of the deciding
factor there and he's not Russell Wilson
but he can get out of some of the
trouble that our offensive line is gonna
put you in so you think he would be the
pick by the Jets over Rosen right now as
we stand eight days to go and then you
say the Browns take Chubb fourth and
then the first Josh off the board goes
to Denver with Allen yeah and that one
could be a trade to me that wouldn't
shock me at all why would that why would
Denver trade out because you sitting
there saying okay if we're comfortable
with Case Keenum for a couple years
let's let's kick the quarterback
decision down the road a couple years
and then let's ride with Case Keenum
let's get somebody that can help us and
that could be an extremely valuable
able slot there because where those
quarterbacks are situated and there's a
lot of love for Josh Allen when you talk
to folks around the league maybe that's
a buffalo maybe that's an Arizona one of
those teams maybe even a Miami
potentially coming up to that fifth spot
John Elway can get a nice little haul
there all right so I want to take a
break because back in 60 seconds you
have Josh Rosen falling out of the top
ten and then you have Lamar Jackson
falling out of the first round
completely and I want to know what
you're thinking about that where you
would believe that might not be the case
and then again you tweet it out you have
heard some bananas crazy rumors and I
need you to put a little bit more meat
on those bones okay we'll discuss all
right we'll discuss that's in 60 seconds
with Daniel Jeremiah here on the Rich
Eisen show
[Music]
Daniel Jeremiah at moved the sticks on
Twitter he has moved the sticks podcast
with Bucky Brooks comes out every single
Monday and Thursday and he will be
sitting on draft night 1 2 & 3 with me
all picks 1 through mr. irrelevant I
drayton rest
Rashmi you and Mayock we got David Shaw
from Stanford night one and then Charles
Davis Chuck D from rounds 2 through 7
with us that'll be fun here's my biggest
challenge right now with this draft
um I've got BJ Hill defensive tackle
from NC State and I've got PJ Hall
defensive tackle from Sam Houston State
info it's it's dangerous it's the kind
of you know that's it's occupational
hazard yeah if you don't make sure hills
and halls brother now TJ's BJ's the
whole thing you can't you can't you
can't yes they the poll question today
brought to you by our friends at Farmers
Insurance bound to take some unexpected
turns Farmers Insurance can help you
understand your coverage options with
our practical knowledge gained from more
than 90 years of experience we know a
thing or two because we've seen a thing
or two find an agent farmers calm yes
first reported by Daniel Jeremiah in the
Washington Post last week until draft
isn't 8 days who is most likely to drop
in the NFL draft which of these four
guys Josh Rosen say Quan Barclay Baker
Mayfield Lamar Jackson I guess that's a
perfect way to start the Honda inside a
report right here brought to you by the
Honda Pilot with you Daniel Jeremiah how
would you answer that question oh well I
would say when I hear drop I think of
expectation versus where you eventually
land yes so when in that regard I could
see it being rosin just talking to
people around the league I think there's
a chance when you've got those four
quarterbacks viewed up there the
consensus seems to be we're going to see
three of them going those top five picks
so that fourth one I could be very well
see a team trade up and get in the show
get them but it mock drafts I don't do
trades in this latest one I have rosin
dropping out of the top ten and even if
we get to draft night and if he slid a
little bit and maybe got towards ten in
that range that would shock me
so why rosin dropping out of the top
I mean what what is going on here yeah I
mean look I always come back to it and
say that my order how I have I'm Sam
Donald Josh rose and Baker Mayfield Josh
Allen right but the ones
Josh Allen just gets so much you know so
much heat and so much love when you talk
to people around the league it's it's
overwhelming so I can't it's I'm just
why you're such a hard worker from
Freddie has been I don't mean I
shouldn't say it in a way that sounds
like I'm denigrating his hard work he
does have hard work he has made himself
into what he is right now he's been
overlooked his entire life right which
is why he's few people have even seen
him play football and I think the fact
that Carson Wentz came from a similar
situation is so spectacular that
everybody thinks he's the next one and
his measurables from the combine mirror
Carson Wentz's that said Rosen has been
working his ass off too mostly but he
gets he gets downgraded for his
intelligence he gets downgraded for his
inquisitiveness he gets downgraded for
being an a-hole basically which you know
we have Trent Dilfer on the show
tomorrow said you know we butted heads
when he was 16 17 but now he's a
different kid I haven't scouts and
executives seen that from him through
this process no I think so and we and we
just did we just put out our Josh Rosen
360 podcast where we talked to his high
school coach we talked to teammates of
his at UCLA we had more on we had
everybody in jail for JD all those guys
so it was great getting some feedback
there look and maybe I'm getting lied to
rich but when I talk to people around
the league the concerns that come up
with Josh Rosen or not personality based
it's more so about the injuries that he
suffered and you know remember when
Bridgewater was coming out so much was
made about his narrow frame you know
Josh is Josh's frame comes up a little
bit and they say can he withstand the
beating that you're gonna take at that
position so I hear more durability
concerns and if you're comparing him
directly with Josh Allen I think it's
better player than Josh Allen but you
talk about you know build I mean those
are Josh Allen's built like a mountain
sure
so there's where that's where some of
that stuff comes in and I say this in a
in the most kind way all right
and I say this is somebody who's how
long were you were scout for eight years
as a scout
having done this as long as I have on
the NFL Network and
being as locked in the NFL Draft as I
possibly can be reading all the stories
that I can possibly read on everybody it
seems to me with all due respect there's
no worse person in sports than the
unnamed NFL scout Chadi Chadi Chadi
Chadi Chadi never putting their name to
it and saying some of the most awful off
the wall crazy things
hmm defend the unnamed NFL scout I'll do
I'll do it for your first couple you
know a couple reasons for it people
always wonder like why are these guys
talking why are the scouts talking and
I'll give you an example but when I
started scouting this the scouts and oh
three oh four had so much more pull and
input in their building and in the
process over the years that's become a
top heavy decision making process so
Scouts have not been as important so
they're out in the road for 200 days a
year they compile all this background
they compile all these notes on guys hmm
and they they're sitting here I don't
have a voice so they reach out to people
that'll hear them because they want to
get their opinions out there now
personally I do a thing called ask five
or I'll ask five guys I don't put their
names on it I've never I never go
negative on that I'll never ask for any
negative information on guys I don't I
don't care to do that I don't want to I
don't want to get in that business I
don't do it I do think there is some
value the guys are never gonna put their
name on it cuz they'll get fired inside
their building but there's some value I
wrote something today on I pulled five
guys on who are who are ideal [ __ ]
you mean ideal fit for a player in a
team so you know I get somebody brought
up you know Calvin Ridley what the
Patriots would make sense obviously the
Belichick Saban connection and and they
lose a Brandon cooks there's a lot of
different things I'd never even really
put those two together so I think
there's something cool that that people
can get from quote-unquote an anonymous
scout but I've never been a fan of we're
gonna bash kids and we're gonna get into
character and all that stuff I don't I
don't buy that well and then the only
person I guess who's less worse but more
just as bad is unnamed NFL executive
like the one who said about Rosen that
we don't need him tweeting about
politics when there was a five-game
losing streak going on again not been
around him he's sitting in that chair I
didn't get that vibe from him mmm-hmm at
all he said he did say that he wouldn't
do that anymore than the f Trump hat
that he wore rights a mistake he was a
mistake even said that
now with Lamar Jackson as well it seems
that there's all this stuff out there
that he that he's uh that his mom being
his manager is discounting him it's
tough to get in touch with him is that
the case with him
well yeah I've heard I've heard all
those your stories are unnamed scouts
misnamed executives yeah and then there
aren't named pundits more people who
talk sports for a living who think that
he's not gonna be good when the chips
are down third down third and long what
do you say to something like that well
look all the stuff with his mom
representing them and all that I think
you can be able to kind of work through
that and navigate that it's a unique
it's different definitely a different
situation especially for a top-tier
quarterback to me it with Lamar we
talked to his high school coach they
changed their offense to fit Lamar when
you talk to the coaches at Louisville
they changed that system to build it
around Lamar he just needs to find the
right people that are gonna change what
they're doing because I don't have a
tough time sliding him into what people
are doing in currently with these teams
that need quarterbacks it's gonna be a
change of definitely a change of
philosophy but we saw Houston navigate
those waters last year when deshaun
Watson took over they saw him totally
morph and change that often to look like
you're watching Clemson truthfully when
you watch Houston so it's just finding
the team that's willing to do that
that's willing to change and do that
well Baltimore has Greg Roman sitting
there on their staff he did that with
Kaepernick yeah he did with Kaepernick
and you've got somebody there's another
Bucky's even talked about this before
there's legs sitting morningway was
there with with mike vick he was talking
about that just yesterday so no and that
would be something that that's
legitimate I could definitely see that I
get mixed signals out of Baltimore when
I when I talk to folks there
I get snot - you're at your old spot ya
know I guess there's there's definitely
if people in the Flacco camp and there's
people in the camp of we need to go find
somebody else
Honda inside a report here with Daniel
Jeremiah so but why would you see Lamar
Jackson with no trades just dropping
right out I just don't know which team
to put him with you know if you were to
say you know at the end of day is he a
first-round pick or a second-round pick
I would I would say I still think he'll
end up being a first-round pick but it's
putting a team to it when you're not
doing trades I think you very well could
see a team that maybe passes on one in
the top part of the draft could come
back in and trade back in we've seen
that numerous times but I just have you
know you here in New England I've heard
New England mentioned with him
and then I just get here sitting here
thinking man Brady's got one or two
years left I trying to get somebody to
take over for him but they've their
track record has been drafting guys
outside the first round so that's not
really the way they've operated
Baltimore you know maybe is that too
early for Lamar Jackson are they gonna
try and get somebody else they have so
many other needs on their roster those
are the two teams that that makes sense
Cincinnati I guess would be would be
another one but to me is that a comeback
into the bottom of the of the first
round situation I don't know I just
couldn't pin him down with one specific
team Daniel Jeremiah here in the Honda
inside a report all right now let's get
to it you tweeted that out of about
crazy-crazy draft rumors look what he
said you tried to you were trying to pry
it you're kind of Primus didn't stand
strong yes because we're sitting here on
this show and we are we don't want false
rumor mongering we don't want that yeah
but but is it actually a specific rumor
it's a rumor of a rumor what do you mean
I mean like there was we were getting
phone calls from people saying from
teams saying there's there's some crazy
stuff going on I mean what are you
talking about right all I'll say is that
it was a lot of it had to send her
around Buffalo and with Buffalo and
their efforts to get up to get a
quarterback so that was that that was
kind of the centerpiece of it but in
talking to folks that are very well
connected in with that organization what
you hear is hey if something does happen
it probably would not happen until teams
are on the clock and that would probably
be the team at number two you keep an
eye on yeah because I'm okay so now I'm
connecting your dots with the ones the
breadcrumbs that that Bucky left here
yesterday yeah and the fact that for the
bills to get up to number two would
probably require somebody else coming
into this trade like an NBA trade in the
way that Bucky said because in order for
them to get up to say six to get to a
beach front position that the Giants
would consider trading out of mm-hmm
because the Giants aren't trading out of
two to go down to 12 that's a long way
to go it's a long way to go so they've
got to get closer to the Giants before
Gettleman is gonna answer a phone call
from western New York saying let's
strike a trade so that's where maybe
we're right in look in all this
Pacific's were not laid out we're just
hearing all this buzz and all these
rumors and just like this is crazy this
is nuts but so I'm sitting here like you
you're trying to put the pieces together
trying to figure out what it is I've
I've heard from a bunch of folks hey you
know Chris Ballard would like to get out
of six you know he's already traded back
from three to six and maybe there's a
chance he could even trade back further
well that's close enough to the Giant so
does that get close enough to the water
you're in quitting Nelson territory or
in territory potentially for a third
quart the third quarterback available
should that be or Chubb yeah if it he at
all possibly drops mhm you don't think
he drops out the top I don't think so
the thing is though all this the
likelihood of getting all these
different parties to agree on something
I'm very skeptical that could happen but
that's just part man there's there's
names floating around there like veteran
names and I'm like get out of here he's
not gonna get treated but you just hear
all this stuff I've never had a year
like this where there's just so much
swirling around tell me their names
Brady said no it's not Brady okay you
just got all sick to your stomach are we
gonna move up now are the Pats moving up
no that's not really their style I think
they're more likely to go and reverse
the way they do it I was about to say we
are we moving up to a higher floor you
meant the Patriots when you said we
we're moving on up to the east side
after that already the Honda inside a
report again is brought to you by the
Honda dream garage spring event the best
part of spring outside of baseball is
exactly that the great deal on the
comfortable 2018 Honda Pilot is
available for you right now at your
local Honda dealer where they're holding
it on a dream garage spring event great
stuff as always thanks buddy I look
forward to it hydrate tape your ankles
and smooches gonna say yeah mooch is on
the outside set with Eggman and Steve
Smith we're on the we're on the inside
set can Dallas outdo Philly that's my
question
here's the Philly was an incredible
spectacle for many reasons one because
of Thor outdoor space okay the rocky
steps and then the outdoor space that
could fit all of 7080 hundred thousand
people on Ben Franklin Parkway that was
incredible the energy was amazing when
the Eagles were on the clock and then
the Drew Pearson moment sucking in all
their hate and spitting it back only to
have Philadelphia win that suit
both out here it's kind of a tough spot
to for Dallas to overcome but we've net
draught halls have been hotel you know
what
dining rooms yeah - Radio City Music
Hall the felt forum I think was once so
at Madison Square Garden
yes Radio City Music Hall in the met
beautiful spot Roosevelt University
Auditorium in Chicago this is gonna be
we haven't seen anything like what we're
about to sing so I don't know is the
answer we will see usually though Texas
football I think well plus you get
advance all from from me from the center
of the country that normally can't drive
to a draft the Bayou all the people in
Northeast is so crazy their fans fans
are going to come from everywhere yeah
in that area so it's gonna be exciting
it's gonna be very can't wait man look
forward to seeing you sir we'll see you
next week that's Daniel Jeremiah Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience